gute 9
so liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
wäre im reichstagsgebäude tagen ist ja
eigentlich keiner erwähnung wert
und dennoch ist es heute eine
besonderheit wir kommen trotz der
pandemischen beschränkungen erstmals
wieder alle gemeinsam im plenum zusammen
und das macht eine überfraktionelle
verständigung möglich die wir eben mit
großer mehrheit bestätigt haben
in der vergangenen legislaturperiode hat
dieses haus sogar wenn nötig einen
überfraktionellen konsens herstellen
können um die handlungsfähigkeit des
parlaments zu sichern die bürgerinnen
bürger schauen auf uns ihre erwartungen
an das parlament sind zu recht groß und
wir sollten weiter alles tun um dem
gemeinsam gerecht zu werden die heutige
abstimmung sollte nicht die letzte
gewesen sein in der wir mit
überwältigender mehrheit über die
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg entscheiden
wenn uns das etwa beim wahlrecht gelänge
wäre ich nach der auch für mich
persönlich bitteren erfahrungen der
vergangenen legislaturperiode
bestimmt nicht traurig
eine wahlrechtsreform die diesen namen
verdient ist allerdings kein deut
leichter geworden und trotzdem sie
duldet ersichtlich keinen aufschub mehr
möchte ich dazu nicht sagen außer dass
jedenfalls nach meinem verständnis bei
einer entscheidung dieser tragweite
eigentlich keine politische kraft im
parlament aus der mitverantwortung für
eine tragfähige lösung entlassen werden
sollte
konsens liebe kollegen entgegen wird in
diesem haus auch zukünftig nicht die
regel sein und das sollte sie auch nicht
hier ist der ort an dem wir streiten
dürfen an dem wir streiten sollen aber
fair und nach regeln leidenschaftlich
aber auch mit der gelassenheit die einer
erregten öffentlichkeit beispiel geben
kann
und wenn wir das prinzip der
repräsentation stärken wollen dann
müssen wir uns immer wieder um die
faszination der großen strittigen
debatte bemühen das parlament ist immer
auch eine politische bühne
und ich bloß eine notarielle
veranstaltung und koalitionsverträge
abzuarbeiten zumal sich die entwicklung
in einer vernetzten welt mit ihren
wechselnden herausforderungen
nichts ein koalitionsverträge hält was
wir eben erfahren umso mehr kommt es auf
das parlament an als den raum in dem die
vielfalt an meinungen offen zur sprache
kommen und das lot noch wichtiger weil
ja in unserer gesellschaft die
bereitschaft sinkt
gegensätzliche standpunkte
auszuhalten widerspruch überhaupt
zuzulassen bei der drang nach
konformität in der gruppe wächst um von
sich fernzuhalten was dem eigenen
empfinden und denken widerspricht
wir sollten den streit in der mitte der
gesellschaft suchen und ihn öffentlich
hier im parlament austragen indem wir
deutlich machen dass nie eine seite
allein recht hat das um der sache willen
miteinander gerungen werden muss
politik ist ja kein selbstzweck sondern
wir die nicht im eigenen interesse einer
gesellschaftlichen gruppe oder einer
meinungsbörse wir so dienen der
gemeinschaft und am ende unsere debatten
stehen entscheidungen für die wir die
verantwortung tragen durch mehr halten
die wechseln können das erleben wir
gerade
ohne kompromisse geht das nicht erst
recht nicht bei mehrheitsverhältnissen
wie nach dieser wahl
aber suchen wir auch nicht immer nur den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner in dem wir
im detail streiten trauen wir uns etwas
zu
ob in regierungsverantwortung oder als
opposition sonst geht verloren was die
demokratie eben auch dringend braucht
politische führung sind verlangt von uns
als abgeordneten den blick für die
wirklich großen aufgaben und die
fähigkeit das gesellschaftliche
interesse auf diese großen aufgaben zu
lenken orientierung zu geben und dazu
müssen wir bereit sein den menschen auch
etwas zuzumuten
nicht nur antworten geben die gern
gehört werden sondern lösungen
entwickelt und zur diskussion stellen
für die aufgaben die wir als dringend
erachten und davon die bürger zu
überzeugen und dazu verpflichtet uns
unser mandat
das mitunter zähe ringen um
gesellschaftliche mehrheiten sollten wir
gerade auch denjenigen nahe bringen die
mit blick auf den klimawandel von der
trägheit
demokratischer prozesse enttäuscht sind
und sofortiges handeln erfordern ihre
motive sind nachvollziehbar aber
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse allein
ist noch keine politik und sogar nicht
demokratische mehrheit wer ziele und
mittel absolut sitzt bringt sie gegen
das demokratische prinzipien stellung
übrigens kann die wissenschaft genauso
wenig letzte gewissheit liefern
und in der demokratie gibt es sowieso
nicht die eine richtige entscheidung und
genau damit müssen wir umgehen
zu beginn
zu beginn der pandemie haben wir ja
erlebt wie groß in einer
gefahrensituation das bedürfnis nach
klaren politischen vorgaben des wir
brauchten
wissenschaftlichen rat
doch der stand der virologie und der
medizin war damals noch recht unsicher
weil es eben ein neues phänomen war die
wissenschaftliche logik die nicht nur
auf konsens sondern gerade auf
antiquität zweifel und widerspruch
beruht geriet ihn ein
spannungsverhältnis zu den dringenden
politischen
notwendigkeiten parlament und regierung
mussten handeln und wir mussten trotz
des unsicheren erkenntnis tanz und im
wissen um die vorläufigkeit
wissenschaftlicher forschung rasch
entscheidungen treffen und dabei
verschiedene disziplin hören die
soziologie die ökonomie psychologie und
pädagogik auch den ethikrat der
natürlich galt es die ethisch moralische
dimension genauso wie die
verfassungsrechtlichen aspekten unserer
maßnahmen mit zu bedenken
und wir haben noch die unterschiedlichen
argumente von interessengruppen
einbezogen und in dieser situation wurde
ja wieder besonders deutlich doch
politik ist immer ein schwieriger
abwägungsprozess ein austarieren
widerstreitender interessen
und dabei darf sie den blick auf das
große ganze nie verlieren das ist
politik
das regierung mehrheiten die suche nach
lösungen nach bestem wissen und gewissen
entscheidungen treffen und sie dann noch
verantworten es berührt unser
selbstverständnis als demokraten aber
wir müssen stets neu beweisen
die großen herausforderungen unserer
zeit im rahmen von
rechtsstaatlichkeit freiheit und
demokratie bewältigen zu können
in der korona pandemie ist es im großen
und ganzen gelungen auch unter enormem
entscheidungsdruck
kontroverse debatten zu führen
und widerstrebende werte und interessen
gegeneinander abzuwägen
auch wenn sich im einzelnen kritik immer
üben lässt die parlamentarische
demokratie hat eine beispiellose
bewährungsprobe bestanden und diese
erfahrung kann uns mut machen für andere
globale herausforderungen die
parlamentarische demokratie es wird im
wettbewerb mit autoritären systemen
bestehen wenn wir als gesetzgeber die
weichen zu stellen dass unsere
regierungsform neben ihrer werte
gebundenheit auch durch effizienz
überzeugt aber hüten wir uns
gleichzeitig vor der versuchung alles
regeln zu wollen politik weiß nicht
alles besser und wenn politik meint sie
habe keine grenzen ist das mindestens
genauso gefährlich wie wenn andere
glauben sie seien keine begrenzungen
unterworfen das prinzip unserer
freiheitlichen ordnung
das prinzip unserer freiheitlichen
ordnung ist eben dass sie begrenzt ist
der souverän hat mit seiner
wahlentscheidung vom 26 september die
parteipolitische vielfalt im bundestag
bestätigt und neue mehrheiten ermöglicht
für
279 abgeordnete beginnt heute ein neues
leben als parlamentarier
behaupte noch einer die parlamentarische
demokratie könne sich nicht personell
erneuern fast 40 prozent aller
mitglieder unseres hauses bringen ihre
lebenswege andere berufliche
hintergründe
persönliche erfahrungen und meinungen
erstmals hier ein
gestatten sie mir gerade an sie unseren
neuen kolleginnen und kollegen eine
persönliche bemerkung
mit diesem mandat das ihnen auf zeit
verlieren ist bei dem man möge nie genau
wissen kann wie lange es dann wirklich
dauert kommt eine außergewöhnlich
erfüllende auf sie zu und zugleich eine
strapaziöse und vereinnahmende zeit bei
allem politischen elan die arbeit auf
offener bühne verlangt dass private auch
zu schützen und seine integrität watt
wer weiterhin zu hören kann und seinen
inneren kompass nicht verliert wer sich
in kollegialität und fairness über und
fairness übt wer sich über die
verhaltensregeln die wir uns geben
hinaus den sinn dafür bewahrt was
anständiges und womöglich noch steigern
was unanständig ist früher hätte man
gesagt was sich gehört und was nicht wir
alle
wir alle repräsentieren als abgeordnete
das volk wir vertreten die legitimen
interessen unserer wähler und partei
aber wir haben immer auch das gemeinwohl
im blick zu halten
und verwechseln wir nicht
repräsentation mit repräsentativität
jeder einzelne von uns bildet nicht
einfach einen teil des volkes ab artikel
38 ist eindeutig abgeordnete jeder
abgeordnete sind vertreter des ganzen
volkes
auch wenn sich natürlich die gewachsene
vielfalt unserer gesellschaft in der
volksvertretung wiederfinden soll der
bundestag wird nie ein exaktes
spiegelbild der bevölkerung sein und wer
repräsentation mit repräsentativität
gleich sitzt wird eine fülle eklatanter
abweichungen finden in beruflicher in
regionaler in kultureller oder
religiöser hinsicht und er leistet dem
ihrigen verständnis vorschub dass
gesellschaftliche gruppen nur durch ihre
eigenen angehörigen vertreten werden
könnten aber wer wem aber
bei wem
bei wem wollen wir dann anfangen und wo
endet dass ein parlament das im übrigen
zwar die vielfalt abbildet aber darüber
keine mehrheiten schaffen kann ich eben
kein parlament
unsere repräsentative demokratie beruht
auf der politischen gleichheit aller
bürgerinnen und bürger
ohne rücksicht auf ihre soziokulturellen
merkmale als parlamentariern muss sie
keine juristin aus der finanzverwaltung
wie fragen der landwirtschaft vertraut
machen und der handwerksmeister
entscheidungen über eine pflegereform
treffen darin besteht das mandat von
abgeordneten
als gewählte repräsentanten vertreten
wir die
repräsentierten nicht durch unsere
person sondern durch unsere politik
durch sie sollten alle menschen
politisch gehör finden der bundestag
bündelt interessen und er trägt damit
verantwortung für den zusammenhalt in
unserem land und deshalb sollten wir uns
immer wieder selbst hinterfragen ob wir
auf unsere parteien der vielfalt an
interessen und meinungen gilt genügend
gehör verschaffen und auch ob die
erwartungen der bevölkerung an
gestaltungsprozesse selbst teilhaben zu
können
ausreichend erfüllt wird
in der vergangenen legislaturperiode hat
sich das parlament mit einem bürger rat
für eine form der de liberati vcn
demokratie geöffnet ich denke dieser
bundestag wäre gut beraten sich noch
einmal intensiv mit den vorteil aber
auch den grenzen dieser art von
bürgerbeteiligung zu befassen
zumal bürger rede einen raum schaffen in
dem unterschiedliche menschen zusammen
kommen einander kennenlernen sich
austauschen müssen miteinander
vereinzelung sword haben wir ja
schließlich mehr als genug mehr
mitsprache heißt nicht automatisch mehr
partizipation und auch nicht
zwangsläufig mehr akzeptanz für die am
ende im parlament getroffenen
entscheidungen und dabei leistet die
repräsentative demokratie
was auf keinem anderen weg vergleichbar
gelingt nicht nur die vertretung
mobilisierbar interessen sondern der
ausgleich widerstreitender interessen
nicht nur fordern sondern auch gestalten
nicht nur entscheiden sondern auch
verantworten und davon werden wir die
bürger jedoch nur überzeugen wenn wir
unsere rolle aktiv wahrnehmen es braucht
ein selbstbewusstes parlament und es
braucht selbstbewusst die parlamentarier
das fordert viel von uns aber das ist
der wille des wählers aber auch die
eigenständigkeit des die abhängigkeit
des einen vom anderen da ist er trank
sich profilieren zu wollen
und gleichzeitig die notwendigkeit als
fraktion geschlossenheit zu zeigen da
ist das selbstverständnis der fraktion
auf eigenständigkeit und in
regierungsverantwortung der druck auf
stabile parlamentarische mehrheiten zu
sichern und dieses spannungsfeld können
wir nicht ausweichen
aber wir sollten uns dessen bewusst sein
und uns um die richtige balance bemühen
denn wir tragen verantwortung dafür
das parlament gegenüber wachsenden
plebiszitären ansprüchen zu stärken und
im übrigen liegt es an uns wie weit wir
unsere gestaltungsspielräume als
gesetzgeber einengen lassen durch eine
rechtsprechung die bis weil mindestens
an die grenzen ihres mandats geht
dazu gehört
dazu gehört für mich dann allerdings
auch
verantwortung die politisch wahrzunehmen
ist auch nicht auf gerichte abzuwälzen
bei uns waren
bei uns eine entscheidung sind wir im
übrigen heute stärker denn je in globale
zusammenhänge eingebunden und die
komplexen herausforderungen lassen sich
nicht mehr allein im nationalstaat
bewältigen deshalb werden wir in einer
welt des rasanten wandels den
bürgerinnen und bürgern auch nur dann
halt geben können wenn wir europa
stärken und zusammenhalten und dazu
braucht es unsere bereitschaft die
anderen besser verstehen zu wollen die
adressen die interessen erfahrungen die
historischen und kulturellen prägungen
der anderen zu kennen und zu
respektieren
ich habe in den jahren in dem ich diesem
haus und verschiedenen regierungen
angehören durfte die erfahrung gemacht
parlament können hier ergänzend zur
regierung manches bewirken als
abgeordnete sind wir es ja gewohnt
unterschiedliche sichtweisen
widerstrebende aber legitime interessen
auszuhandeln wir haben in drei vor drei
jahren mit der deutsch-französischen
parlamentarischen versammlung eine
weltweit einzigartige binationale kammer
geschaffen die übrigens in der pandemie
eindrucksvoll bewiesen hat wozu sie in
der lage ist wir können darauf stolz
sein und wir sollten darauf aufbauen
aber vergessen wir bitte darüber auch
nicht die besondere mittlerrolle die
deutschland für unsere mittel- ost- und
osteuropäischen nachbarn zukommt auch
und gerade diesem parlament
leisten wir unseren beitrag dazu dass
sich die spaltungen in europa nicht
weiter vertiefen
und auch ein persönliches wort zum
schluss ich habe in den vergangenen vier
jahren in diesem haus ein
fraktionsübergreifend hohes maß an
unterstützung und respekt im amt des
bundestagspräsidenten der fahrer dafür
bin ich dankbar und ich hoffe und der
bitte es auch für meine nachfolgerin die
wir heute in dieses amt wählen
als abgeordnete haben wir alle die
gleichen rechte
darüber hat der präsident die
präsidentin zu machen mit aller kraft
aber wir haben auch alle die gleichen
pflichten am verhalten jedes einzelnen
von uns auch das mussten wir zuletzt
wieder erfahren hängt die würde dieses
hauses wir haben es in der hand ob die
bürgerinnen und bürgern dieser
volksvertretung das schenken worauf die
parlamentarische demokratie aufbaut
nämlich ihr vertrauen ich dann gehen
[Applaus]